big podcast a big guests Heidi and
Spencer not bad for like my third guest
only ET was behind the scenes of Kaitlyn
Bristowe spod cast one show off the vine
with special guests Heidi Montag and
Spencer Pratt you're gonna do in the
show or you're they're also trying to
get you to do more reality TV do you
think that's in your future are you just
happy podcasting for now well I think if
you're strong enough couple you can do
it they've obviously made it through and
that's so impressive to me um and I
don't
I'm really happy podcasting right now
but we also had to get Kaitlyn to weigh
in on that big bachelor nation breakup
Ben Higgins and Lauren Bushnell I think
it was tough because they also jumped
into another TV show after The Bachelor
where we kind of went back to somewhat
of a normal life not really normal we
were all over the map but we didn't do
another TV show and we kind of just
really got to know each other after the
show and I think it's just I mean any so
many couples won't work in this world
and they were one of them so it is what
it I'm you loser exactly now not to jinx
you and Sean because I think you're a
strong couple but when Ben and Lauren
split we had this big question come up
because the rings go back less than two
years but if a couple stays together
past two years then what happens with
the Rings July 27th it's mine seriously
get to keep it I think it will they have
to do that you know you have to put a
contract together for that kind of thing
it's it's not a small ring um so yeah I
think it's two years so if we broke up
after I get people you also said that
ABC never offered you a televised
wedding if somebody offered you a
televised wedding today
would you sign on board are you offering
me a wedding maybe you've heard of your
from um yeah we're not opposed to it
because so many people are so sweet and
invested in our relationship and have
asked
and want to be a part of it and the fact
that we could have that opportunity to
share it with people who care about us
it means a lot to us you guys are all so
you've said you're no rush to get down
that aisle
yeah no clearly we are not usually July
27 she's keeping the ring yeah that's
what we're waiting for then I might die
he's getting gonna hock this neck
[Music]